- On a universal geologic timescale,
how might we think about or define
sustainability of humanity,
as we become a multi-planetary species?
Sounds like you're dubious of
our multi-planetariness.
- I am.
So I don't know how to
answer the question,
quite in the context you...
I do think it is, naive of us
to imagine that in a few generations,
first of all, that we
could cooperate enough
together to actually transform, say Mars,
which seems the best prospect,
into anything like a hospitable place.
Without so much high-tech intervention
that it's not really
going to be relevant to
the most of the rest of
the population of Earth.
Because of my understanding of the way
the Earth's system has evolved.
The Earth has not been the same
through all of its history.
I think that's one thing that has changed
in my time as a Geologist
of 30 years or so.
We see that Earth's story
is kind of a bildungsroman.
It's a developmental story,
and Earth has had many different modes.
Certainly the biggest
biogeochemical change
was the great oxygenation event
that happened about
1.85 billion years ago,
where we went from an atmosphere that was
probably mostly CO2 and water vapor,
to one that at least had some free oxygen,
not 21% like we do now, but some.
Which changed all the
biogeochemical rules,
and then there was a second jump,
only about 600 million years ago,
to something like near modern values.
So there are really different
chapters in Earth's story,
and maybe that could be
sped up a little bit,
on another planet.
But I mean the timescales here are large,
and we don't even know
all the players involved.
We have only a tiny fraction
of the microbes in the world
classified and understood in
terms of their metabolisms,
and what they're doing
for us behind the scenes,
so I just find it very naive to think that
we're gonna be able to go
to another planet and manage
biogeochemistry on that scale.
Yeah.
- Do you think going there and...
(audience laughs)
Yeah, I agree with you.
I think though that there's
even value in going and failing.
That the showing of the
difficulty, in a way...
If a few humans get there
and they can barely survive,
and pretty much have to vacate,
or can only survive,
from massive influxes
of energy from Earth,
and supplies that--
- I would argue we can
do that with modeling.
(laughs)
- Well we can, but I don't think
it changes the global perception, right?
So it's...
I think one of the things
you're talking about
is changing global perception and I think,
there's all kinds of things
that happen from exploration
that are beneficial, I think, to humanity
that are intangible in other
ways that going to Mars--
- I'd like to see the price tag,
and see whether we could put
that same amount of money
toward other efforts,
and I mean there was the Biosphere 2.
People may remember this
from the early 1990's.
This closed ecosystem or allegedly closed,
in the Arizona Desert,
where maybe it was the
scale, it was too small,
but even on that scale,
with everything quantified
and inventoried very well.
They were not able to
control the oxygen levels,
and finally had to open the place up,
because the people were
getting really cranky,
and irritable with each other,
because they were getting only 14% oxygen,
and the problem was that
there was too rich soil
in the agricultural
sector of Biosphere 2,
and even though people
had tried to calculate
exactly how much CO2 that
soil would be respiring,
they were way off, and within a couple of,
I think it was closed
for about eight months,
but they had to open it up, because...
People were just unable to function.
They had altitude sickness
essentially, the whole time.
- Right
Yeah, somehow I think these
experiments are helpful,
for humanity, because I
think a model is a model,
but having, watching humans suffer
is a little bit different,
and probably will capture
imaginations a little bit better